i think a common complaint about the
many worlds interpretation is that it
adds so much to quantum theory you might
have heard that there are like these
infinite number of worlds and that just
seems really excessive but i'm going to
try and explain in this video why
mathematically actually the many world's
interpretation is a simplification of
quantum theory it takes quantum theory
that has itself some really nasty
mathematical properties in particular
there's two rules of quantum mechanics
that literally contradict each other
they can't both mathematically be true
it takes one of those rules and just
deletes it so it takes what's called the
measurement collapse rule that
measurements cause superpositions to
collapse and just deletes that rule
and that's it that is the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics i'm
going to explain why that is still
possible why you know just deleting a
part of quantum theory would still give
you basically the same results it took
the example that i'm about to show you
to convince me that that really is the
case and that the many world
interpretation i think is the best
interpretation of quantum mechanics
because it's so simple so we're going to
start by talking about what exactly the
problem in standard quantum mechanics is
so this is called the measurement
problem
here are the rules of standard quantum
mechanics so the first one is
quantum states are vectors
that probably doesn't mean a whole lot
to you so i'm going to show you an
example that will help explain what that
means so suppose i have an electron
electrons have this special magnetic
property called spin and what it does is
it determines how the electron is going
to behave in the presence of a magnetic
field
so there are these machines called stone
gerlac machines they're basically
machines that make a non-uniform
magnetic field so that the electron has
sort of two choices it can either go
upwards
or it can go downwards now i'm going to
talk about the state of that electron
before it goes into the machine
so it could be in a state that we'll
call spin up
this is just some funny notation to to
talk about the state of a quantum thing
don't worry too much if it looks scary
but okay if it's in state up what that
means is it will go up so an electron
that was in up will go
up
on the other hand if the state had
instead been down
then yep predictably it would have gone
down
but here's the weird thing about vectors
you can have combinations of them the
state of this electron could have been a
combination of up and
down the whole time now if that was the
case what happens to the electron
quantum theory would say that well
because it was in both of those states
it needs to go both ways it needs to go
up
and down
which is very weird but that is the
first rule of quantum mechanics by the
way i've left off some factors that you
may or may not know should go in there
i'm going to leave them off for this
whole video
because i don't think that it changes
the analysis much in this example but
just so you're aware they're supposed to
be in there
let's look at the second rule i would
call this the schrodinger equation
the schrodinger equation is just
basically a rule for telling you how the
state of an electron will evolve over
time so it says you know if i put this
electron into a certain magnetic field
or if i did something else to it what's
going to happen to its state it has to
change but how is it going to change so
that's all the schrodinger equation is
then we have the final rule and that is
the problematic one
it's this
measurements
cause
collapse
so for example suppose that i had put in
a little detector here
and here
so what these detectors do is if this
detector sees an electron in the bottom
path it will alert this machine and then
the machine will point
to down
but if the machine sees the electron at
the top path then the machine will point
to
up
so it's just a measuring device that is
going to measure whether the electron is
up or down what do you think would
happen if we put in an electron that is
a combination of up and down and we
measured it
well the sensible thing to assume is
that you would see both somehow there
would be like sort of two arrows and it
would point to both up and down but that
isn't what happens
in fact this rule says that the
measurement causes the state to collapse
from this superposition to just one and
which one it's going to be random so in
this case it'll be 50 50 odds
so let's just say that it happens to
collapse to being just down
that means that this
machine
will measure it being in the down state
and from now on
now that it's measured it the state is
down and remains down
so why is this measurement rule so bad i
mean the other two seemed weird enough
themselves right but the reason why the
schrodinger equation and the measurement
rule can't coexist is because they
mathematically contradict each other so
in the schrodinger equation
everything is evolving in time in a way
that doesn't lose any information about
the previous state so if you look at the
state now you would be able to tell what
the state was just before that isn't the
case at all if you have measurement
collapse once the state collapses you
have no idea exactly what kind of state
it was before that so there's this
abrupt change in the state of the system
which yeah the schrodinger equation
doesn't allow
another reason why that's so weird is
because both of these rules apply to
you know quantum objects and so you
might think okay quantum objects are
just like atoms and things right but
what is inside of this measuring device
if not just a bunch of atoms
so
why is it that
this measuring device despite just being
a physical object just despite being
made of regular stuff like anything else
obeys completely different rules to the
rest of the quantum mechanics and what's
the arbitrary line like what counts as a
measurement does it have to be very very
big
well bohr certainly thought so he
imagined that there was a certain line
where the classical world starts and
where the quantum world stops but like
exactly how big is that does it have to
have like i don't know 10 to the 23
atoms and then it's classical or below
that it's quantum
i think that's kind of ridiculous why
should there be an arbitrary line in the
sand where this rule starts applying and
this rule stops applying in any case
quantum theory doesn't give a precise
definition of measurement so you never
even know when you're allowed to be
using this idea of a measurement or not
so
this is the measurement problem this is
what many worlds is trying to fix i
already alluded to it but the way that
many worlds tries to solve this is by
just removing that rule altogether some
of you might have watched some of my
videos that i made on bohmian mechanics
and you might be like thinking yeah well
biome mechanics also solves measurement
problem it does and in a sort of similar
way so it also removes this measurement
causes collapse rule but then it has to
add a few extra rules so some equations
for
how the state of the objects are
governed by the schrodinger equation
um and yeah like it's it's a little bit
of extra structure on top of regular
quantum mechanics so i still really like
it i think that it is a very cool
demonstration of how you can get the
same results um but with like slightly
different maths what i really love about
the many worlds interpretation is that
it's not adding any extra structure on
quantum mechanics at all it actually
just
removes this rule and that is it but
surely that's not going to work out i
mean if you just remove this rule then
what would happen here you would have
had this state starting like this
and then since there's no measurement to
collapse it wouldn't that mean that when
you do the measurement you see both of
those options happening
but we know that that isn't what happens
when we do measurements in the lab so
like surely this is wrong surely this
can't be enough to get the same results
as all the ones we're used to from
quantum mechanics
all right in a moment i'm going to go
through this example again and we're
going to see how it is enough to
actually remove this statement and still
get all of the predictions that we would
have made
with regular quantum mechanics
before we get to the many worlds
interpretation though i want us to go
back to regular old quantum theory and
figure out what measurements really are
so in quantum theory it's not exactly
well defined whether something counts as
a measurement or it doesn't so i think
it makes sense for us to go back to
regular quantum theory and understand
measurements a little bit more because
then we have a better chance of being
able to get rid of them entirely let's
see if we can come up with a very
clear-cut experiment that we can do that
tells us whether
the measuring device that we're using
really is a measurement or isn't all
right so this is the experiment that i
propose we do to be able to tell whether
something's a measurement
first we have a stone garlic machine
just like before
and so that causes an
electron that's in the up state to go up
and down state to go down as before
but now i've got another stone garlic
machine that i've just flipped upside
down
and what that means is the magnetic
fields are all reversed so everything
goes back as it was before
so electrons that were in state up go
back to the center
and so the ones that were in down
and so this by itself is like nothing
happened
so if i have a quantum state
let's say
this
when it goes through here it changes but
then it changes back to what it was and
so it comes out exactly the same as
before
so for example if i had an electron that
was an upstate it goes up then it goes
back to the center and it still stays in
that upstate
now this is the extra bit that actually
does something um and it's a another
stone garlic machine that i've taken and
just flipped onto its side and so what
it does is it has a magnetic field in
the sort of left right direction so it
splits electrons that way
what is going to happen to our electron
that is in the upstate it went along
this path
and now what's it going to do when it
goes to here
well for this we're going to need a few
little facts from quantum mechanics and
i'm going to write them down but i don't
want to freak you out if you haven't
seen them before don't worry about it
i'm gonna tell you what they are and all
i want is for you to get the gist of
this experiment you don't need to
necessarily get every one of the details
so here's the first little fact
all right so what this says is that up
is equal to right plus
left
that should seem weird to you because it
is but this is just a standard fact from
quantum mechanics how it applies here is
that okay well there's this up thing
it's still up when it gets to here and
then we can stop thinking about the
electron in terms of up and down and
instead think about it in terms of
right and left
by the way there are some coefficients
that i've left off here and here but
they're not important because they're
both equally big
so that means that because this thing
that is in the upstate
is
in an equal amount left and right
there's an equal probability so 50 50
that the electron ends up here
and 50 50 that it ends up here
so if i do a
a measurement here
right and left
then there's a 50 50 chance that it will
point to either one of these let's just
say for now that it happens to point to
the left one
so that means that you found the
electron in the left state but it could
have gone either way
now a very similar analysis applies for
if the electron had instead
started off in the down state
nothing would have happened to it here
so it's still in the down state
by the way you're probably wondering why
there's this whole thing here that just
does nothing we'll get to that in a
second because we're going to add
something in the middle that changes the
setup so okay if this was in the down
state it's still in the down here we're
going to use this fact from quantum
mechanics this is equal to right minus
left
again
that should strike you as weird uh it is
weird i'm not going to explain it but
let's see what the consequence is so
this thing if we start thinking about it
in terms of up and down start thinking
about it in terms of right and left
is now equally in the right state and
the left state and so just the same as
before it could equally well turn up in
either of those spots
and so when you do the detector it'll
show one of them with 50 50 probability
let's say again that it ends up being
left
okay interesting
now let's see what would have happened
if instead
we had started off
with the equal superposition up and down
all right again nothing happens to it so
it's still this
okay good
um but now is it going to go to both
sides equally seems like it should i
mean like this part of it does and this
part of it does
so surely the combination of them is
equally likely to be left and right
but that is not correct because we can
add these two together according to this
rule and see what we get all right so
let's figure out what this combination
is by adding those two equations um so
it seems like there should be two rights
because those two rights add up together
actually there's just one because uh
i've missed off a bunch of factors like
i told you before and if you took all of
those into account it would actually
just only be one
um so that's right
but then what happens to the lefts well
they cancel each other out right one of
them is positive one's negative and so
you get this bizarre result that the
equal superposition of up and down is
equal to right
okay
again this is standard quantum mechanics
but it is a weird result this is what we
refer to as interference because it's
like you add these two things where you
know what the individual behavior of
both of them is but the combined
superposition behavior is not that
right it's not 50 50 it's actually just
a hundred percent going to go right and
so let's see when you put this through
the machine
comes out here this is right and so
the result is going to point
to the right for sure um good so this
has given us a way of verifying whether
the state is a superposition state or
not but that wasn't our question
originally our question was when does
something count as a measurement
so
here's what i'm going to do
i'm now actually going to put something
in between here
so something happens here
there could be a range of things that
happen it could just be a regular old
measurement device that measures whether
it was up or down
it could be a regular measurement device
where for some reason you just can't see
the screen and it's out of view
or it could be that someone else has
done that measurement and then they ran
off with the result and they didn't tell
you either way you don't know what the
result of the measurement is you don't
even know if it really counts as a
measurement for example maybe someone
tells you i did a measurement but how do
you know that they're not lying well
this is an experiment that we can do
that will let us verify whether a
measurement really happened at this
point or not here's how it goes
suppose that a measurement did happen
right
so now the state goes from being in this
equal superposition
to being one of them because we know
that measurements cause collapse we
don't know exactly which result it was
could be either up or down with 50 50
probability let's just say it's up but
it doesn't matter
um if it was up now at this point
the state is up
and if you do this measurement
well we know that up is an equal
probability of left and right so you
could get either of these suppose we
actually did get left
on the other hand if no measurement
happened there's nothing that happened
here so this whole thing is nothing and
the state is the same afterwards
and we know that this superposition
state is the sum of these so it's just
going to go right
so this setup lets you decide whether a
measurement really did or didn't happen
at this point because if you had a bunch
of electrons that started off in this
state
and there was no measurement here
they're still in that state and they're
all going to go to the right but if you
started in the state and a measurement
happened then 50 of them are going to go
right and 50 are going to go left if you
didn't get every single detail of that
set up don't worry about it the point is
that now we have a way of telling
whether a measurement really happened or
it didn't happen and so now we can go
and do this experiment and actually this
experiment or very similar to this
experiment has been done and so let's
see what does and doesn't count as a
measurement
the result is lots of things count as a
measurement for example if a measurement
was done but you just didn't see the
result that doesn't matter
even if
no one saw
the result i think this is an
interesting one because a lot of people
have this misconception that a
measurement is only a measurement if a
conscious observer looked at it but that
isn't true a machine by itself can do a
measurement and this is a way to verify
it because the interference goes away if
you did do that measurement something
that obviously doesn't count as a
measurement is if that
measurement device is off
yeah clearly it can't be doing anything
but there's still a question here it's
like how big does the measurement device
have to be to be able to count
how many atoms need to be inside
is it
only going to be a measurement if
tons of atoms in there or is it okay to
just have a very very small measurement
device that's going to be our next
thought experiment
i'll give you the takeaway of this
experiment before we even do it we're
going to use just one particle as our
sort of detector in the standard
interpretation of quantum mechanics a
single particle absolutely cannot cause
measurement collapse we know that
because
if it did then we wouldn't get all kinds
of states and quantum mechanics that we
need
these are called entangled states and
like for example the whole theory of
quantum computers relies on entangled
states being able to exist and we have
made entangled states in the lab so we
know that
you know a single particle cannot be
causing any sort of measurement collapse
but in this example we're going to show
how a single particle can for all
intents and purposes
make it look like the state of the
electron has collapsed how is that
possible when i've just said that it
didn't collapse
well the thing is that if you lose track
of that particle the one that was sort
of doing the measuring
if you lose track of that measurement
particle then
basically there is no way for you to
tell anymore that the electron is in a
superposition even though it is even
though the electron is still in a
superposition
and no collapse has happened because you
lost track of the measurement device it
looks as if the measurement is done and
it collapsed
pretty cool
all right here's how it goes
so the particle that we're going to talk
about
is going to go in here what this means
is the electron if it's in a
superposition will go both up and down
since this particle is in the way of the
down path it's going to interact with
anything that is in the down state so if
an electron comes by in the down state
its state is going to change
i'm just going to say that it has two
states
we'll call them
u so it starts off in u
but then if it interacts with an
electron coming on the down state
that will go to d right so it has these
two states
what happens if an electron is in a
superposition the way to think about
something like this in quantum mechanics
is to think about each part separately
and then to add them together so let's
think about the part where the electron
is in the upstate
um what happens then well this
particle starts off
as a u
so i'm just going to write it next to it
and
the electron nothing happens to it it
just flies by it's going this way and in
this case nothing happens to
a particle either it just stays in the u
state because it didn't interact with
anything
on the other hand
if the electron had been in the down
state
sure this particle would have started
off as a u
but
something would happen to it
so the electron would still fly by
without a care in the world
but now our particle would end up being
in the d state
and like i said if we want to deal with
the superposition so that's
up
plus
down
put some brackets around that so we
don't get confused
this is the case where we have up plus
down but this other sort of measuring
path particle starts in the state u
that's what i've written down here again
don't worry if the notation looks very
strange it is
what happens to this
well it's the sum of what happened to
the other two
and so i'm gonna write those out
so
for the up bit
it's this
and for
the down bit it's this
some of you might recognize this as a
maximally entangled state or a bell
state
these two particles have become
entangled you can't talk about what this
particle is doing without also
referencing what this particle is doing
as well but you can see that this state
is a quantum superposition you know it
has this plus in it so it means that
it's doing really both of those things
so in the same way the electron is now
going through both of these paths this
thing is in the state of both having
detected the electron and having not
detected the electron
so this like you can see is essentially
a measurement if i could just take away
this particle and then measure it to see
whether it's in the u state or the d
state it would also tell me whether the
electron is in the up state or the down
state but we're not going to do that
we're going to let this little particle
go off wherever it wants and forget
about it we've just got our electron
what do you think is going to happen
when we put it through the rest of this
experiment
is it going to act as if it's been
measured or is it going to act as if
it's not been measured there's kind of
arguments that you could make for both
possibilities for one this hasn't been
measured we know that we know that this
was not technically a measurement the
state is not collapsed the electron is
still in a superposition of doing both
of these things but on the other hand
this really does look like a measurement
in a lot of ways so what's going to
happen let's let the maths figure it out
so the way to do this kind of maths is
like we did before we stopped thinking
about the up and down states and instead
we start thinking about the left and
right states so we're going to take
these equations and sub them into here
so i'll just go ahead and do that okay i
just rewrote this state up here so i
have a little bit more room um but by
the way you might think it's kind of
weird that we have to keep talking about
what the red particle is doing even
though it's now long gone you know it's
flowing off so why is it that we have to
keep talking about it when we're talking
about the state of the electron
unfortunately we're forced to because
the mass of entanglement means that you
literally just cannot write the state of
this electron without talking about the
red particle anymore so
we're gonna have to just keep that there
okay so all i've done here is that i've
taken the up and used this rule put it
into here taken the down and converted
it using that rule put into here i
totally understand if you're like what
is this mumbo jumbo what are all these
crazy arrows everywhere
look don't worry about it too much but
the point is that we're kind of going
from thinking about everything in the up
down basis um to the left and right
basis because that is going to tell us
what is going to happen when we do this
measurement
you might remember that's exactly what
we did before when you know in the other
case where there was no red particle
there's nothing there we had this and
then we had rewritten it
by sort of substituting in both of those
things
as
this
plus
this
plus
that minus
that
i'm going through that very fast but if
you remember this is why we figured out
that if there was nothing happening here
nothing had happened here at all then um
this state would have just gone to the
right
because
this and this cancelled and you ended up
with just the right component
is that what's going to happen here is
this thing going to go right let's see
all right what happened here this is
just how we do expansion it's not too
different from how you're probably used
to
but
this bit and this bit become that i've
been in that bit become that
if we take step back from the
mathematics though what this is saying
is actually very interesting
it's saying that this state
that's here
before it goes into this machine
is a very interesting superposition of a
bunch of things it's a superposition of
this particle being a state up in other
words it detected nothing and the
electron being left and right so that's
those two states
and a superposition of that plus this
particle having detected something and
this electron being in a superposition
of
to the right and minus to the left
okay so it's great that this minus is
still there because it looks like it
should be able to cancel in the same way
that these minuses left but are we able
to do it we want this
to cancel with this
do you see the problem like sure these
terms look kind of similar but they're
not the same this one has a u here this
one has a d and so in other words
they can't cancel
there's nothing that you can do extra to
simplify this state well what does that
mean then for this experiment is this
particle interaction going to count as a
measurement in which case
it's going to go 50 50 either way or is
it not going to count as a a measurement
in which case
it will 100
go to the right so the way to do this is
to just count up the weight of the terms
that are growing to the right and the
weight of the terms that are going to
the left and as you can see they're
equal
and so there's a 50 50 chance of the
electron going either way and that means
that someone who is doing this
experiment will decide
a measurement must have happened let me
just reiterate how weird that is so it
looks to a person who is trying to
verify whether a measurement did or
didn't happen that a measurement
happened but we know by looking at this
maths that no measurement happened a
measurement in quantum mechanics is a
collapse the state has to break down
that's not what happened every part of
the state is still there the up
component is still there the down
component is still there
but for every way that you can try and
verify that a measurement did or didn't
happen it will look like the measurement
happened so what's going on
the thing that's going on is that that
extra particle that red particle
is taking away a bunch of information
about this electron with it and whenever
that happens
now it will look to anyone else who
doesn't have access to that red particle
like the electron has collapsed that
doesn't mean that it really has and the
way that you would be able to verify
that it really hasn't is by somehow
going back and tracking down this red
particle bringing it into another
experiment where both of these particles
are present and measuring both of them
so you could do what's called a bell
measurement for example and you'd be
able to tell that these are in a
non-collapsed state but if you don't
have access to that red particle you
have no way of telling that in fact the
electron is not in a collapsed state
and so that is kind of how many worlds
works many worlds says that measurements
real measurements the type that quantum
mechanics goes on about don't happen
there are no collapses instead there are
interactions like this interaction with
this red particle and whenever an
interaction happens
you know a few atoms interact one of
them just flies off could be a photon
going away at the speed of light if you
don't have access to that particle then
to you it will look as if collapse
happen and so you don't really need
collapse to be there at all i think this
is a super beautiful solution to the
quantum measurement problem and by the
way
i've only shown it to you for this very
simple example but you can
mathematically prove that this works in
any case um if you want to know more
about that i would recommend looking up
decoherence there's a couple of books i
really like about it if you're
interested i'll put them in the
description some of you might be very
confused right now like how is this
thing that i just showed you just a
bunch of maths in this little example
many worlds isn't the many worlds
interpretation about how every time a
measurement happens the world splits
into two and uh there's like many copies
of yourself in different worlds and all
this like extra stuff that sounds really
crazy well like i think that many worlds
is just like a bad name for this thing
that stuff does happen but it isn't
fundamental instead it's an emergent
property so let's go back to the example
to see why in fact
it will look
like the world split let's get rid of
everything and then let's talk about the
many worlds point of view
so let's say that
i'm going to do a measurement here of
whether this electron is up or down
it's
me the state of the electron starts off
as a superposition of up and down but
the standard interpretations of quantum
mechanics would say that when this
person measures then the state has to
collapse to one or the other so perhaps
we get rid of this one
and so this person
they're in the state where they have
seen the result up
so that's the standard description
but here's how many worlds would see
this
collapse never happens so what happens
to this person are they going to see one
or the other or are they going to
somehow see both
no what they're going to see
is
up
if the electron is up and down if the
electron is down
so that is the new combined state
if you remember this is very very
similar to what had happened when
instead of this person being here we had
just had that one particle interacting
so what does this mean well you might
object that like of course this person
should be able to tell that they're in a
superposition there's suddenly two of
themselves like surely they would notice
well they won't because how can they
notice
every measurement that they're going to
try to do to verify that they and the
electron
are in a superposition will not work
remember when we had done it with this
particle instead so instead of this
person being here
we just replaced it with this single
particle
after that whenever you try to do any
experiment
whenever you try to do any experiment
that would be able to verify that this
electron has in fact not collapsed you
weren't able to find any evidence of
that it would look for all intents and
purposes like the electron had collapsed
and so this person is just unable to do
any experiments she might try this one
she might try some other ones she can
try anything she wants she can try to
verify that this electron
is in a superposition and therefore
there are two versions of herself
but she won't be able to every
experiment that she does will look for
all intents and purposes like the wave
function really has collapsed and this
means that she loses access to the
version of herself that saw the other
result
so there's
this version of her that saw the up
results
and there's this version of her that saw
the down results and they will not be
able to speak again
these two parts of the wave function no
longer have any interference between
each other there is absolutely nothing
that you can do on this branch to figure
out that there is another branch
but because this is all emergent it is
possible to reverse this whole thing
remember that the schrodinger equation
and all of the normal nice parts of
quantum mechanics are time reversible
whereas collapse real collapse is not so
it is possible for this person to
basically
undo everything that happened in that
original experiment to put herself back
into one person
but to do that she would have to take
all of the atoms in her own body and her
mind in the measurement device every
single thing that interacted and
basically put them back to where they
were originally and that is a really
difficult task the more atoms that are
involved in the so-called measurement
the harder it is to ever put the two
parts of the
universe that were twained by that
measurement back together and so that's
why
for all intents and purposes it's like
you have two separate worlds
okay so that was the many worlds
interpretation explained pretty badly
and pretty fast
i am on holiday so i hadn't even planned
to make this video but i've been
promising it for three years so i
decided to just kind of do it off the
cuff but i'm sure that loads of bits
were not explained well so how about you
leave me comments for the bits that you
would like to see properly explained and
i can either do a follow-up video or
just make this video again entirely i'll
leave links to whatever i end up doing
around here somewhere
thanks